حسنًا، يأمل رئيس الوزراء الإسرائيلي
في تحسين العلاقات مع المملكة العربية
السعودية، وتأتي رسالة مماثلة من
ولي العهد السعودي الأمير محمد بن
سلمان يقول إن البلدين
يقتربان من تطبيع العلاقات،
وتجري المحادثات بشأن الضمانات الأمنية الأمريكية
والمساعدة النووية المدنية
للرياض.  إلى جانب التنازلات الإسرائيلية المحتملة
للفلسطينيين،
لدينا مفاوضات جيدة مستمرة
حتى الآن وعلينا أن نرى إلى أين ستصل،
ونأمل أن تصل إلى مكان
يسهل فيه حياة
الفلسطينيين ويحصل على إسرائيل
كمسرحية.  الشرق الأوسط، لذلك تعتقد أنه
إذا كنت ستصفه، فهل أنت
قريب
كل يوم نقترب أكثر، يبدو أنه
لأول مرة أه حقيقي جدي، سنرى
كيف ستسير الأمور وقد
حذرت ولي العهد الأميرة من
وصول البرنامج النووي  أما الهدف من
بناء الأسلحة النووية
فلن يكون أمام المملكة العربية السعودية خيار سوى تطوير
قدرات مماثلة